[Music]
well good morning
good morning and welcome back hmm if I
could ask everyone to take a seat try to
get the volume level down just a little
bit too much freedom may be in this
group good morning welcome good morning
and welcome to our second day of this
Hillsdale College national leadership
seminar in case you missed the program
last night my name is Tim Casper I work
at Hillsdale College in the external
affairs department where else to serve
as deputy editor of an Primus and I have
the privilege of teaching in the
politics department at Hillsdale College
before we get started I wanted to say
for the record that when I said last
night that Frank Luntz had three hours
to speak I was joking again welcome I'll
be our emcee today before introducing
our first speaker I'd like to point out
that the college has some literature
tables set up outside of this room there
are lots of publications they're put out
by the college including issues of in
Primus I mentioned last night that the
circulation of an promise is bigger than
ever but it's not big enough so keep
keep sending us those names and we'll
keep adding them to the list
our first speaker this morning is sharyl
Attkisson
she's an Emmy award-winning
investigative journalist and the host of
Sinclair Broadcast group's Sunday
morning news program full measure
previously she has been a correspondent
for CBS News and an anchor and
correspondent for CNN for five years
while at CBS she hosted health week 1/2
hour weekly medical news magazine on PBS
she's a graduate of the University of
Florida College of Journalism and
communications and she spent the early
part of her career working in local news
as a reporter an anchor and producer in
Florida and Ohio she's received multiple
awards for her work in addition to her
Emmys these include the Barbara Olson
award for excellence in independence in
journalism and the Edward R Murrow award
for excellence and investigative
reporting
in the midst of her excellent reporting
work she also finds time to write she is
the co-author of a college textbook and
author of two bestsellers the most
recent of these is the smear how shady
political operatives and fake news
control what you see what you think and
how you vote fake news is the subject of
her talk this morning please welcome to
the podium cheryl atkinson
can you see me I'm so short I can't see
you hi Molly
so the subject of the talk was requested
that I speak about his fake news a myth
and I thought I'd begin with an informal
fake news survey so question number what
is going to be when do you think the
term fake news in its modern context
started being used and argued about I'm
going to give you four choices I'll let
you know in advance what they are was a
pre-2012 was it during the 2012 campaign
then again more so in 2016
was it an early 2015 as the most recent
presidential campaign began or was it
less than two months before the 2016
elections so if you think fake news came
up pre 2012 raise your hand
mm-hmm during the 2012 campaign for a
little bit but then more so in 2016 okay
how about early 2015 just during this
election cycle and then fourth choice
who thinks that came up about less than
two months before the election was over
yes you people are right
number two who invented the phrase fake
news in its modern context your choices
here are the left the right the media
and Donald Trump who thinks it was the
left who thinks it was the right who
thinks it was the media who thinks it
was Donald Trump I have some information
for you all today that will surprise you
I too was surprised the answer the
question is fake news first arose in its
modern context as far as I can tell
about two months before the election
seem like we've been talking about it
for years we had not been I did a pretty
thorough search on this as a research
for my book looking for the origins of
this of this I was surprised too I
remember though looking back that I
first heard a hint of it when President
Obama gave a speech and it was on
October 13 2016 at Carnegie Mellon in
this speech he insisted that somebody
needed to step in and curate information
in the wild wild west media environment
I thought it was strange because
literally absolutely nobody was asking
for any such thing people in the public
were not saying please government or
please third party step in and curate my
information for me but I knew it was no
accident or off-the-cuff remark because
when the president makes a speech like
that and comes up with an idea it's an
initiative it's an agenda so what was it
I wondered and whose interest did this
know did this notion serve my question
was who wanted to control the
information we were receiving on the
internet and on the news and why if you
think about it the Internet is really
kind of last bastion where you can get
every kind of idea imaginable for better
for worse uncensored so if the
government for example were to try to
shape or censor a topic well the
Internet is the great equalizer if the
government of the corporations or the
news media we're to try to controversial
eyes certain topics or sense of them
well you can still go and exchange these
ideas on the Internet who is it who
doesn't want that to be the case is the
question so let's back up a little bit
and look at the origin of fake news
before it was called that fake news has
pretty much always been embedded in our
culture just wasn't called that for
example the 1950s and 60s some of you
may remember the supermarket rags
they gave popular rise to blatantly fake
news like front page images of aliens
impregnating unsuspecting and usually
large breasted earthling women right we
all knew that was fake news but there
are lots of examples of fake news
surfacing in mainstream news so here's
just a few of them in 1996 you may
remember a news media frenzy wrongly
blamed a security guard named Richard
Jewell for the Atlanta Olympic bombing
remember poor Joel we were chasing him
around at his mother's house the media
had pretty much convicted him in the
headlines every day we later learned
poor Jule had actually been a hero
moving people away from a suspicious
backpack before it exploded also in the
1990s the press widely reported that a
Chinese scientist named Wynn wholly had
stolen the design plans to our most
sensitive nuclear warheads warhead
secrets which is called the w88 and I
broke the story at CBS News that the FBI
had actually framed the scientists lying
about his polygraph they said that he
had failed when in fact he had passed
with flying colors and the government
had actually leaked the false
information to a willing press on 9/11 a
TV network news reporter falsely
reported that one of the terrorist
planes crashed in the presidential
retreat Camp David never happened and
yet they never corrected that by the way
in 2014
you probably remember this when Rolling
Stone reported on a sensational case of
a fraternity gang rape that turned out
to be so unsubstantiated that Rolling
Stone retracted the article and the
reporter was found guilty of malice and
a defamation lawsuit and here's a huge
one that I don't hear people talk about
much in 2014 the police shooting of
Michael Brown remember day in and day
out the hands up don't shoot scenario
was reported on its it launched
movements it launched riots
well eventually even the Obama Justice
Department eventually said that the
entire hands up don't shoot scenario was
probably fabricated and they said the
police officer actually acted in
legitimate self-defense
I'm sure you can think of a hundred more
examples but why didn't we call any of
this fake news when did that begin and
why well the first widespread use of the
phrase in its modern context that I
could find was exactly one month before
that President Obama speech at Carnegie
Mellon on September 13 2016 a nonprofit
called first draft announced a
partnership to tackle malicious hoaxes
and fake news reports seem to be a
legitimate thing they said the goal was
to separate wheat from chaff and prevent
unproven conspiracy talk from figuring
prominently in internet searches to
relegate today's version of the alien
baby story to a special Internet
oblivion
then came President Obama's speech the
topic of fake news suddenly dominated
headlines from this point on every day I
mean it seemed to me as if the media
have been given its marching orders fake
news they insisted was an imminent
threat to American democracy in November
a month later President Obama continued
his hard sell against fake news this is
2016 he said in a speech if we are not
serious about facts and what's true and
what's not
we can't discriminate between serious
arguments and propaganda then we have
problems if everything seems to be the
same no distinctions are made then we
won't know what to protect we won't know
what to fight for I didn't know what he
was talking about mind you this was all
the beginning of the campaign that we
soon saw to aggressively fact-check not
only some in the news media but every
word that trump utters or tweets not as
predecessors or his opponents mind you
but Trump and it was also the beginning
of the push that we saw for Facebook and
Twitter and other third parties to judge
and call out supposedly fake news but as
a reporter who studied the industry that
seeks to manipulate us on behalf of paid
interests I know that few themes that
arise on the news or a few things
distributed through politicians arise
organically a noted propagandists I
interviewed for my book the smear told
me you know nearly every image that
crosses your path and daily life or on
the news was put there for a reason
often by
I'm gonna pay a lot of money to place it
there my question was was the whole anti
fake news campaign an attempt to shape
our views and limit our access to
certain information by labeling selected
websites and stories as fake and
controversial izing them but who would
be doing that in the job that I have I
find that if you follow the money you
often get a lot of answers to questions
so I want to know who is behind the
funding for that nonprofit first draft
and it's anti fake news campaign I did a
little digging what really wasn't very
hard it turns out the funding came from
Google Google's parent company alphabet
was headed at the time by a man named
Eric Schmidt who happens to have devoted
himself to Hillary Clinton's election
campaign offered himself up as a
strategist to her campaign and is listed
right now on open secrets as her number
one campaign donor through his company
alphabet with more than 1.6 million
dollars so his company funded this
nonprofit first draft around the start
of the election cycle so it's no
surprise that Hillary Clinton supporter
and surrogate david brock next turned up
prominently in the anti fake news
movement on December 5th 2016 Huffington
Post published an opinion piece from
Barak that seemed to blame conservative
fake news for Hillary Clinton's defeat
Brock wrote this fake news is an
existential threat to our democracy for
the first time in our history we have a
Minister of disinformation Trump advisor
Steve Bannon who commanded a vast
proto-fascist media empire operating
from a plum perch in the West Wing the
next day
Brock held a conference call detailing
his plans to remake his flagship smear
group Media Matters into something new
an effort that pivoted from being a Fox
antagonist he said into an arbiter of
what he called alt-right fake news
outlets all conservative of course Brock
announced that he would be working
personally to pressure Facebook and
Google to better filter out fake news
the first order of business he said is
for some of these companies to adopt
standards and clean their own
now for a little background in context
counting just two of Brock's super PACs
and he has a whole host of LLC's and
nonprofits and super PACs and all kinds
of groups under different names but just
for the two super PACs
he had collected and spent more than 50
million dollars in Liberal donor money
in the 2012 and 2016 campaigns to try to
get Clinton elected or to support other
liberal causes was he privately blaming
the freewheelin internet for his
machines failure to convince enough
donors to vote or enough voters to vote
for Clinton despite the fact that
Clinton raised far more money than
President Trump and was able to dominate
the mainstream news and social media
narratives so completely that almost
everybody thought that Clinton was gonna
win but the irony of brought going after
fake news wasn't lost on a lot of people
one of my friends wrote to me who's a
journalist the ultimate huckster has
announced he's going to lead the fight
against fake news a conservative blogger
wrote in an article virtually everything
that david brock does would qualify as
fake news under any objective criteria a
day after Brock made his announcement by
the way he resigned from the Citizens
for responsibility and ethics in
Washington which is called khru it's one
of the groups he had taken over and
transformed from a watchdog into a
highly partisan campaign tool to attack
Republicans he said he was retiring from
that position because he needed more
time to devote to his anti fake news
campaign the next day the intensely
political nature of this movement became
clear when Hillary personally jumped
aboard the anti fake news Train she
spoke this was in December of 2016 to
reporters after meeting with members of
Congress she claimed to be appalled by
what she called the epidemic of
malicious fake news and false propaganda
that flooded social media over the past
year again I think there's a lot of
irony there because Clinton herself has
a long-standing relationship with fake
news she had falsely blamed a YouTube
video for the September 11th 2012
Benghazi terrorist attacks while
acknowledging privately in emails from
the start that she knew Islamic
extremist terrorists were
she'd falsely said that we had dodged
sniper fire on a trip in Bosnia nobody
shot at us and she'd falsely claimed
that she never handled classified
information on her private servers the
FBI says it found 2093 classified emails
including some that were top-secret but
in her appearance at the Capitol
Clinton tells reporters it is now clear
that so-called fake news can have
real-world consequences now at the time
she was referring to the arrest of a
gunman who had fired shots at the pizza
restaurant named in pizza gate you
remember the pizza gate scandal the
suspect was apparently motivated by
online fake news reports lives are at
risk Clinton declared it's a danger that
must be addressed and addressed quickly
it's imperative that leaders in both the
private and public sectors step up to
protect our democracy and innocent lives
by the way don't you think it's sort of
an odd coincidence that the owner of the
pizza restaurant involved in pizza gate
was a former David Brock boyfriend it's
a true story
just days after Brock and Clinton
announced that they were gonna go after
fake news Facebook cracked it announced
new steps to curb the spread of fake
news
CBS reported at the time that that step
was the result of months of public
pressure as far as I could tell the
months of public pressure came not from
the public at large but from special
interests executing an orchestrated
campaign in fact Brock would later tell
his donors his and Media Matters that he
was largely responsible for forcing
Facebook's hand but suddenly everybody
was talking about fake news it was on
the headlines day in and day out
then along came Donald Trump the wild
card probably the only politician that
could have her would have been able to
change this dynamic and kind of turn the
campaign on its head each time advocates
cried fake news Donald Trump called them
fake news he made his rallying cry at
rallies and he called out CNN Trump
redefined it basically fake news he said
was mainstream news organizations
reporting false information or making
mistakes due to sloppiness or
so now the right had its definition the
left had its definition the left move
forward with its efforts to establish
systems to curate or control their idea
of fake news problem is of course who
they were appointing as the curators
some of them had conflicts of interest
with the entities that their
fact-checking
some are guilty of so-called fake news
themselves so let's look at a few
examples of that we already mentioned
google and alphabets ties to the Hillary
campaign but before that Google advised
Obama and Google representatives in fact
were invited to more than 420
closed-door meetings in the Obama White
House Facebook's new plan
to help crack down on fake news included
collaborating with pointer Institute's
PolitiFact ABC News factcheck.org The
Associated Press and Snopes now this
audience probably already knows the
possible perils of all that from a
neutrality standpoint its relying on
some of the very organizations that have
gotten caught in compromising situations
or engaged in transactional journalism
or reported biased and incorrect news
themselves let's take ABC for instance
ABC has been accused in the past of
shelving or skewing negative stories
about its corporate parent the walt
disney company ABC miss reported that
there was a possible link between the
conservative Tea Party and the killer in
a mass shooting in Aurora Colorado
remember that one 2012 ABC News
routinely allowed TV host George
Stephanopoulos to conduct political
interviews throughout campaign 2016
without disclosing his status as a
Clinton Foundation donor and a former
top aide to President Clinton after it
was appointed as a fact checker ABC was
the very network that falsely reported
that president Trump's former national
security adviser Michael Flynn was going
to testify that Trump had directed Flynn
to contact the Russians false fake news
but they're judging fake news anywho
according to Facebook each fact-checking
entity would be given access to a tool
to evaluate stories that may be
inaccurate if the chosen fact-checkers
agrees story is misleading the story
would get a disputed label stamped on it
and then an article reference explaining
why it's supposedly false so now in
March of 2017 that Google funded
nonprofit first draft they released
their own field guide to fake news which
I looked through it included a category
described as anti-liberal fake news
sites but none that were anti
conservative apparently under the
definition used by first draft and its
partners there aren't any left-leaning
bad actors that are worthy of mention
only right
meantime Trump kept up the drumbeat and
worked his supporters into a frenzy with
his own campaign against his definition
of fake news he managed to co-opt the
term so completely but this kind of
cracked me up in January of 2017 even
some of the entities that were
originally promoting the phrase started
running from it and crying uncle for
example the Washington Post wrote it's
time to retire the tainted term fake
news in fact it's now commonly missed
reported that it was Trump who thought
up the phrase actually it was just a
hostile takeover
you get a drink we'll go on so that kind
of takes care of the genesis of all this
fake news stuff but if you see the anti
fake news campaign as I do an effort to
control certain information and censor
other information with the media's help
it's an extension of a phenomenon I call
transactional journalism or the black
market information trade what do I mean
by that I mean the friendly mutually
beneficial relationships that have
developed between reporters and those on
whom we report it's when relationships
cross a line beyond chumminess and the
players strike clandestine business
deals whether formally are implicitly to
report on people and topics a certain
way reporters may offer favorable
treatment in exchange for giving what
they call a scoop they may agree to let
an interview subject dictate terms and
topics and timing of publication they
may promise to ask some questions and
avoid others they may carry on cozy
relationships that allow their reporting
to be influenced in ways they don't
disclose to the public
usually reporters are for the most
favorable treatment to those with whom
they're ideologically in sync all of
this crosses an ethical line in my
opinion transactional journalism results
in a perverted dynamic public officials
basically manipulate us in the press
into competing to be first to receive
the government and political propaganda
self-serving rumors or press releases
promoting agendas and smearing opponents
and let me tell you how it works in the
newsrooms the reporter who's first to
publish these handouts gets a hearty pat
on the back from colleagues and their
bosses great get they say and the news
business a great get used to mean to me
that you as a reporter got an exclusive
story as a result of your ingenuity and
shoe-leather journalism and persistence
today it simply means that you're the
recipient of a White House or political
party leaked transactional journalism is
basically a vehicle that serves as a
smokescreen it makes narratives appear
to be organic hard-nosed
journalism when they're the exact
opposite topics and people make news now
because it's all been pre-arranged
pre-planned and agreed upon when I first
started reporting at a national level
I listened as colleagues and managers
spoke in awe of many stories broken by
certain noted journalists and
publications the rest of us were often
sent chasing after their exclusives you
know see if you can get what they got
why couldn't you get that story but
after a few years I learned that many of
these stories were not the result of
hard work and digging at least not on
the part of the journalists the
reporters were simply willing
repositories for propaganda by operators
and smear artists who literally call
them on the phone and leak information
that they want reported as if it's
somehow news rather than propaganda or a
press release simple as that
it's hardly reporting in my book in fact
when I went to journalism College to the
University of Florida one thing that
really sticks in my mind is they told us
a lot of people will come to you with
press releases and talking points and
things they want you to report you do
not report that if it's something that's
interesting and may be a starting point
for a story and then you have to ask
yourself which part of the story do I
have what else do I need to confirm to
get the whole story maybe you've got
part of it maybe some of it's true maybe
some of it isn't
but it's not something that you
published that's called propaganda today
instead of recognizing these so-called
exclusives for what they really are
handouts from players advocating for
their interests or smearing opposing
views we in the news media covet them
and perpetuate them and encourage this
whole syndrome work in Washington DC
long enough and you get wise to what's
really happening you tell your managers
the objects of their desire these
stories that they see the competition
get that they want a little more than
press releases that certain special
interests weren't publicized for their
own advantage some managers get it but
some tune out they just wish you had the
exclusives and it's not just in this
country when I was writing the book the
last book the smear a US smear operator
I spoke to who worked on a foreign
election campaign told me how he
discovered much to his delight that many
knew
publications overseas are overtly in the
tank for one political candidate or
another actively shaping the artificial
reality that the public sees the news
publications attempts to influence votes
go far beyond typical endorsement are
common on the editorial pages they use
their news stories to construct a
desired reality here's what he told me
two foreign newspapers called me and
basically said tell us what you want us
to report give us the information and
tell us when you want us to publish it
obviously that kind of service was good
for him and his candidate it was to my
benefit he told me but even I thought it
was kind of outrageous here in the u.s.
there have always been questionable
dealings between some reporters and the
interests they cover whether Democrat
Republican or corporate interests but
thanks to the persistent nature of email
we actually have some documentary
evidence that exposes the black market
information trade in some specific cases
that we will discuss right now it's
basically revealing the transactional
nature ship of relationships between
news makers and the media every day's it
should it shows that deals are being cut
in secret backs are being scratched one
hand is washing another it makes it easy
for special interest to accomplish a
smear or put forth their agenda emails
dating back to Obama's first months in
office unmasked transactional journalism
conducted by Washington reporter mark M
bender from the Atlantic he's also
written for New York Times New Yorker
Washington Post vice hotline ABC News
and CBS because I guess his brand of
journalism is what they want this
particular transaction I'm gonna read
you takes place July 15 2009 as
Secretary of State Clinton is set to
make a speech now under normal
circumstances a speech like this isn't
considered very newsworthy sort of a
boring speech at a think tank tank type
of thing and her aide Philippe Rhines
might normally have to work pretty hard
to get anyone interested in covering it
but in today's dynamic an advanced copy
of the Clinton speech would be heralded
as a great get and so Amador wants it
the question is what is he willing to do
to get it in an email exchange the
Clinton aide Philippe Rimes tells am
banned or the reporter there are certain
conditions he must meet in order to get
the text of the speech
Amanda replies okay so Hillary's aide
Rhines dictates in a numbered list
number one you and your own voice
describe Hillary's words as muscular
number two you note that a look at the
audience seating plan shows that all the
envoys envoys will be arrayed in front
of her which in your own clever way you
can say is certainly not a coincidence
and meant to convey something and number
three you don't say you were blackmailed
this is all in writing notice ambetter
say I'm sorry but I'm a journalist and I
can't really be dictated to like that
we're just gonna have to take a pass no
he emails back got it here's an excerpt
from a mother's final article when you
think of President Obama's foreign
policy think of Secretary of State
Hillary Clinton that's the message
behind a muscular speech that Clinton is
set to deliver today to the Council on
Foreign Relations he also noted the
seating arrangement the way Clinton's
aide had demanded once these emails
became public
it was around February of 2016 the
Atlantic issued a statement that said
this is not typical and it goes against
our standards Amand are insisted the
emails didn't capture the totality of
his communications and weren't
indicative of his normal reporting
techniques he said the way Rhines had
described the Clinton speech it was
muscular so I found the adjective
appropriate so muscular was my word no
one fed me anything period well I did a
little searching on Google it must be a
coincidence then that I found other
reporters who thought up the exact same
unusual adjectives when describing the
same Clinton speech Washington fixture
Mike Allen of Politico formerly of the
New York Times and time also called that
same speech muscular and noted the
seating arrangement the way Clinton's
aide
instructed an vendor to do likewise the
headline at New York magazine used the
word yes muscular and the article
actually had a cartoon of Clinton with
bodybuilder arms in it it's just one
example of why I say when you notice the
news media or pundits all seizing upon
similar terminology it's reasonable to
suspect it might be an orchestrated
effort more emails on July 26 2009 when
Secretary of State Clinton appeared on
NBC's Meet the Press
the reporter Anne bender emailed Clinton
aide Rhines adoringly she kicked a in
2010 after Clinton press conference and
bender gushed in another email this is
an awesome presser she's pitch effing
perfect on this stuff moving on to
different topics different people
there's more secret collusion between
news reporters and federal officials to
be found in emails between the CIA and
Kendall a nyan an AP reporter who had
previously covered the CIA for the Los
Angeles Times the emails these are from
2012 revealed a surprisingly deferential
and collaborative relationship according
to the intercept which obtained the
emails Delaney ins interactions with the
CIA include him explicitly promising
positive news coverage and sometimes
sending the press office of the CIA
entire story drafts to review prior to
publication this is a stark departure
from normal ethical practices here's
what he wrote I'm working on a story
about congressional oversight of drone
stock strikes that can present a good
opportunity for you guys he told the CIA
and he added that the story will be
reassuring to the public later Delaney
ins sent the CIA press office a draft of
his story and invited them to weigh in
this is where we are headed he wrote
asking if they wanted to push back on
any of this later he emailed the CIA a
softer version according to the
intercept and asked does this look any
better emails from 2013 show politico's
mike allen greasing the skids with
clinton
Rhines now to set the stage for this
Obama is about to be sworn into a second
term
Clinton is leaving her Secretary of
State job post Benghazi and she has
presidential aspirations well it turns
out Allen has some of his own
aspirations he wants Rhines
Clinton's aide to arrange a high profile
interview with Clinton's daughter
Chelsea to get it
Allen offers to sacrifice the basic
tenets of journalism here's what he
wrote this would be a way to send a
message during an arguably no one
besides me would ask Chelsea a question
and you and I would agree on them
precisely in advance
he continued bargaining by offering up
favorable conditions as he imagined how
the Chelsea interview would play out
this would be a relaxed conversation our
innovative format always gets heavy
social media pick up the interview would
be no surprises I would work with you on
topics and would start with anything she
wants to cover or make news on quicker
than a network hit and reaching an
audience that you care about with no
risk sounds kind of like a used car
salesman
now it's an unmitigated ethics violation
for a reporter to offer to agree on
precise questions in advance and
conference with the person he's going to
be interviewing or their representatives
at least it used to be that's because it
results in secretly pre-scripted events
that require play-acting by both sides
fake news despite Alan's alluring offer
he doesn't get the Chelsea interview in
2015 the whole email exchange was
obtained and publicized by the gossip
website Gawker which sardonically
commented Chelsea Clinton ultimately
declined Alan's generous offer not to
ask her any questions that she didn't
already know about okay so here's a good
one
Alan replied to the fuss once the emails
were made public with a brief item that
he wrote in Politico titled my bad in it
he brushed off the gaffe as clumsy as if
he'd been misunderstood you may have
missed a Gawker post last week that
rightly took me to task for something
clumsy I wrote in an email to Philippe
Rhines seeking an interview with Chelsea
Clinton at a political brunch and the
email I said I'd agree to ask to the
questions to be asked in advance I have
never done that and would never do that
he insisted his explanation seemed
oblivious to the contradiction was he
misleading Rhines at the time or as he
misleading us now he continued Politico
has a policy against it and it would
make for a boring event as you know from
attending our events they're spontaneous
conversational news driven a scripted
back-and-forth would be a snore we
didn't do the interview with Chelsea
Clinton and we would never clear our
questions but the email makes me cringe
because I should have never suggested
that we would we retain full unambiguous
editorial control over our events and
questioning that explanation makes me
think of Orwellian doublethink so I
actually went to my 1984 book looked it
up and wrote down this definition to
know and not know to be conscious of
complete truthfulness while telling
carefully constructed lies
power of holding two contradictory
beliefs in one's mind simultaneously and
accepting both of them to tell
deliberate lies while genuinely
believing in them to forget any fact
that has become inconvenient so this
pretty much sums up might take a fake
news and the transactional journalism
that helps make it possible and why I
say when you watch the news I recommend
you do it as I do and ask yourself who
wants me to believe that and why and I'd
be happy to take some questions
so we have time for some questions it's
a little cozy in here we do have two
microphones it'd be patient and we will
bring the microphone to you thank you
Jeff Myers from Summit ministries the
Facebook CEO is in front of the house
today was in front of the Senate
yesterday and it didn't seem like the
senators or representatives have been
able to get the right questions of him
to kind of get it what they suspect
Facebook is doing how would you approach
that if you were interviewing him today
well you assume as one might that they
want to get at certain things with
Facebook I look at everything in a
really twisted way because of where I
come from today members of Congress in
my view rarely hold hearings on
interests that lobby as greatly as
Facebook in fact facebook lobbies so
that there will not be hearings and
regulations on them and they have huge
lobbyists up on the hill so I wondered
why are they holding this hearing this
is very unusual and that both Democrats
and Republicans agree that also makes me
suspicious I'm sorry that's how I am I
figured it out
this is just my theory sorry Zuckerberg
wanted to do the congressional
appearance he asked to be able to do the
hearing so that he could alleviate fears
and concerns and build public confidence
in a very public way in light of this
data breach this is how he wanted to do
it and so you know with some exceptions
there have been some tough questions
from some members but in general this is
good for all of them they look like
they're holding Facebook accountable and
the type of hearing they don't normally
do anymore
Zuckerberg I believe one of the hearings
so he gets to reassure the public and
kind of set the record straight and calm
things down that's what I think is going
on
Mika and Joe a question about Mika and
Joe and how do they get away with what
they do there no they're nothing more
than the view revisited in the morning
and they don't seem to really have
anything profound or add to the
conversation they're so biased and how
do they keep their job well there's a
market for that a lot of people love
Mika and Joe you know I don't think
ratings are huge on these cable channels
in general but there's a market for
putting out certain ideas and narratives
very popular with this audience I wrote
in one of my books about we're talking
to each other a lot now
Mika and Joe really aren't talking to
middle America they're talking to
Washington insiders and New Yorkers and
political people they're distributing
information and propaganda and ideas
that appeal to a certain group of people
and news organizations as we all know
have somewhat transformed in the last
couple years things that wouldn't have
been allowed before at least we would
have pretended to try to be down the
middle or somewhat fair that's all been
thrown out the window this is a whole
new dynamic and I assume what they do is
rewarded internally and complimented and
well-regarded
this is kind of ancient history about 20
years ago I was the regional consultant
for birthright a pregnancy aid
organization and I was hosting a
gathering in Albuquerque and a
journalist from the newspaper wanted to
interview me which she did and then the
article that ended up in the paper just
made cursory mention of our gathering
and 90% of the article was devoted to a
spokesperson for Planned Parenthood and
I just wondered how do you avoid this
kind of thing when you know you would
under most circumstances like to have
some kind of publicity well I think it's
very difficult to avoid I mean what I've
learned to do
I've been on the receiving end of
interviews since I quit CBS News and
have written some books some people want
to interview me sometimes they're kind
of hostile people and I have my own
techniques for example who was the guy
interviewed me on MSNBC Chris Chris
Chris what no young guy right on before
Rachel Maddow Chris Hayes so he
interviewed me and it was a pretty long
interview I hope I'm not gonna him mixed
up with also an interview that the CNN
media guy did brian Stelter but anyway
one of them interviewed me for a long
time
brian Stelter was hilarious cuz he just
kept asking the same quantum difference
errs and kept asking the same thing and
I finally said try to be polite but I I
knew who's gonna edit this and I kept
saying I'm gonna keep giving the same
answer to that question whatever it was
and when he would ask me a question he'd
try to sound tough but when I would
answer and the cameras on me he'd be
going like it was all a game you know
we're all playing this cute game or
something and I thought he's going to
edit this down to this little slice of
something that looks a certain way
there's not representative of this
conversation so with either he or Chris
Hayes when something similar happened I
actually tweeted out in advance that I
did a great interview with whichever one
it was and that if the whole thing
didn't air I would be putting forth a
transcribed version on my website for
people to see because it was a really
good interview the rest of the interview
so
whichever one it was again this was a
couple years ago it was supposed to be I
think edited down to a five-minute
segment they aired the whole ten minutes
like later in the show they found a big
spot for it I don't know if it's because
I said I was gonna put the transcript
out because I had recorded it but I
think it helped I don't know what you do
when you're you're really at the mercy
of the reporter and I think it's
worthwhile to get your view forth but a
lot of times it's just not going to be
the way you hoped and the way you wanted
you know I I guess that's just the
chance you take today or even 20 years
ago Russ Maneri what sources or what
ways do you use to find credible
reliable information in other words how
do you sift information to maintain your
rudder how do you do that it's um it's
sort of just more a technique I've
developed over 30 years that has to do
with listening to people that you run
into at the ground level not the stories
that they're trying to push to you PR
firms call and try to push you stories
and give you research I try to find out
well who what's the other side of that
why is that narrative being put out and
I assume that anything that comes to me
if I stumble across a whistleblower I
start out going this is someone trying
to trap me in some sort of lies so that
I will be discredited so I always start
with any story that I hear that it has
to be proven and I try to make it a
tough sell that's from my own safety and
because I know people are trying to ruin
or discredit or get me to publish
something that they could point to
that's inaccurate so I have well
established over a period of years good
sources and most every important facet
of kind of government and corporate
maybe not every in a lot of important
facets of government and corporate
worlds where I have people who've proven
very reliable and trustworthy in the
past on many topics who can refer me to
others to trust or who I can go to over
and over again on
maybe a medical topic or maybe a
business topic so I feel like I've just
developed a good circle of human sources
and I know I even know some people that
some groups I use you know you want to
get an opposing viewpoint on something I
know which ones have proven reliable and
I know which ones are less reliable and
I may still use their viewpoints because
it may be necessary to get their
viewpoint but I try to know where they
come from in terms of how accurate
they've been in the past and that's just
kind of come from longevity I think it'd
be really hard to start out today trying
to do that from scratch yes Michael
Lowery from cara's Springs the speeches
that Republicans make listening to
Donald Trump the people in the Trump
administration going back to Bush the
first Bush the second why can't the
conservative values that are underlying
what we think are republican values why
can't they get across on television in
the interviews why do Republicans seem
so one-dimensional in the media I think
Molly will be a great one to answer that
question later
Molly Hemingway I'm not a student of
politics so much it seems to me that the
Republican Party has been dominated at
least in the press by the portion of the
party that for example doesn't like
Donald Trump and the portion of the
party that is less conservative and then
the party leaders such as Ryan I hear
the complaints from members on the hill
but before him Boehner have made sure
that the members who have views that
you're discussing they it's harder for
them to obtain important positions the
leadership in both of both Democrats and
Republicans have become very
heavy-handed the members don't have a
lot of independent choice and how they
vote in hearings they hold and
investigations they conduct so maybe
there are quite a few out there who feel
that way and want to do that but they're
being controlled from the top and my
sense is they're being controlled from
the top because of certain money
interests that are pulling strings
that some of those who are donating in a
really major way cannot be looked into
or investigated or cannot be the subject
of certain hearings and so everybody's
got to kind of fall in line into this
weird extra-constitutional system that's
been developed on Capitol Hill but yeah
you chefs Molly that later because I
know she has good insight on that Fred
botcher wit in Colorado and just since
you're part of the center of gravity
over there in Virginia and Washington DC
I was just wondering all the forces with
President Trump are against him I mean
there is no he's really like a lone wolf
in the whole world that is Washington
the whole corridor the United States and
things like that wait what do you think
what are your thoughts about you know
the things that he I believe in what he
was trying to do I believe in some of
his programs he's trying to put together
do you think he has a chance at all well
I would say yes only because he's
already accomplished the impossible and
every time things sounded the most dire
in the media about him that he you know
he was just toast and he was melt Time
magazine twice had pictures of him
melting like a wax figure on the cover
during the campaign and he won and
that's despite the Machine of the media
and Democrats and Republicans fighting
him I'm not sure there's ever been a
candidate that's had all of those forces
and social media so roundly opposed to
him and yet he's still won so that's the
one thing that makes me think he might
be able to succeed but I think the
opposition against Trump comes from a
different place than some people I don't
think it's so much ideological because
we all know members of both parties are
happy to compromise with distasteful
figures as long as those four figures
are in their camp kind of on board with
them Trump is outside the money system
that they have spent really decades
building and I moderated a town hall
debate with Jim Messina
who's the big Obama and Hillary data man
you know the Democrat data person and
Karl Rove who is
the equivalent on the Republican side
both of them hated Donald Trump at this
town hall and just laughed and laughed
about the idea that he could possibly
get elected both said that they would
love to run against him because he's
such a terrible candidate but it was
clear to me that you know billions of
dollars have been made in Washington DC
from interest both Democrat Republican
many overlapping buying access and
building a structure that's been built
with corporations and companies of a
structure for access and making sure
things certain laws get written a
certain way and not written another way
and hearings do and don't happen and it
would have been okay if either Bush had
gotten elected or Clinton because this
structure operates the same way with
both sides but Trump was the one that
would come in and all the people that
they've paid and all the you know hands
that have been greased this is different
it's not that he won't have his own
ideas and favorites and even perhaps
conflicts but they'll be totally
different than these systems that have
been built for decades in Washington DC
that's my perception of why he is so
disliked my hero was rush limbaugh and
one of the things he does his producer
finds sound bites of a dozen different
broadcast journalists on the same topic
and they all say the same thing and
using the same words where do they who's
on high who's giving them those words
well a couple different things it's a
good question I discussed this quite a
bit in the smear and I have examples of
I believe was after Donald Trump's
acceptance speech at the convention and
everybody decided it was dark
remember dark dark dark dark dark doctor
headlines and all the there's a lot of
things you could have said if you really
I didn't think it was so I thought that
was interesting number one but number
two let's say it was there's so many
descriptive words you can use synonyms
but everybody picked dark and so I put
that on the book kind of compiled it and
it turns out that I believe during the
speech
Clinton's campaign manager I don't know
was Podesta or somebody had actually
tweeted
out that it was dark sort of like the
signal so some of it is it's not really
an order from on high some of it is just
sort of the club' feeling you know
they're not a lot of original thought I
thought when I got into journalism that
there would be a lot of free free
thinkers but in fact there's a lot of
groupthink in journalism so some they're
not even doing it on purpose but it's
just a lot of copying each other you
know how I can tell you because I've
been on some of these Sunday programs
not mine full measure which is original
does not do what I'm about to tell you
but most the Sunday programs I believe
when some of the anchors prepare for
Sunday shows they come in early and they
spread out the New York Times and The
Washington Post and maybe a couple other
publications all you know the print
version and they look and they see what
other reporters have been writing about
the topics they're about to give
thoughts on they're not coming up with I
mean to me they're not coming up with
our own thoughts as much as they're
deciding which ones they agree on in the
main publications they read so that's
kind of how I think this groupthink
happens and that's partly how these same
words get used all the time but when you
see that that says to me always that
there may be another side of the story
or somebody is putting that out and they
know how reporters work that that will
get picked up hi my name is Kim Munson
and with the Ameri tics radio show I
also served on City Council of Lone Tree
Colorado from 2012 to 2016 one of my
responsibilities as I served as the
representative to the Colorado
communications utility Alliance that is
where I saw a real push during the Obama
administration for net neutrality I
didn't understand it but I detected
something wrong and of course when
Donald Trump then pushed back on that
everybody there was a big brouhaha can
you talk about net neutrality please so
I tried to research net neutrality
because it's sort of like fake news no
one had ever heard of it one day and the
next day I had crazy friends of mine
going like you gotta keep the net
neutral and it's got you know just I'm
like what are you talking about and they
couldn't tell you like if you really
asked them to go beyond the first
sentence they had read an article maybe
but they really didn't know what they
were talking about so I tried to read
articles no one writing the articles
seemed to know what they were talking
about I'm not kidding they would all
just say stuff like I used to think when
I thought this I was just like crazy and
uninformed but now that I'm old I'm like
no they don't know what they're just
writing and they don't know what they're
saying you know so I tried to read the
the actual bill or regulation and it
wasn't public so I'm like so everybody's
writing about something that's never
been made public that's only been yes
what oh I should tell me he knows
something about net neutrality it's like
come on up you can tell me but the best
I could figure without having read the
actual publication was if you decide
that every narrative as I do is being
put forth by some special interest
usually a money interest the money
interest behind this seemed to be the
telecom companies like Verizon were
fighting with the cable companies like
Cox and there was something to the
benefit of the telecom companies and
something to the benefit of Cox and they
were lobbying Congress that's why
Congress was on net neutrality I'm sure
they couldn't tell you what it means
either but this was a battle between
these companies and I'm not sure anybody
many people fully understand it but
remember we were all gonna die from net
neutrality of exactly hi my name is rich
Bacigalupi I'm from six miles across the
water from this lady Whidbey Island
Washington states there's a few of us
that made it out of Washington to be
here today
unwashed where I live in Western
Washington it's it's hardly a bastion of
open thought
however where we live I try to bring
forward community discussions and
community forums and some of them been
actually the the Hillsdale lectures we
show those where we live and lots of
people come out for him I'm trying to
put one on now on fake news and so I
approached our local newspaper editors
and people who kind of control the media
flow where I live and they've been very
hostile to the concept of wanting to
have an open discussion on fake news as
I call it willful ignorance or feigned
outrage that I would even approach a
newspaper editor to even comment on the
topic of fake news and he even went so
far as to say that I was questioning his
journalistic integrity to even ask him
to be part of a panel so I'm not giving
up but I want to put this forum on where
I live but maybe in your advice how do
you approach people who would be on both
sides of the spectrum
I'd say conservative or progressive or
however you want to look at it to be
part of such a forum where how what
would you say to someone like that and
say I want you here I'm not questioning
your integrity but I think from the
beginning they're feeling targeted as
fake news so that's my question to you
if I want to put that on how would I
approach it with these people it's a
good question because I think the signal
has been given that now it's time to
retire the tainted term fake news now it
doesn't mean what they wanted it to mean
so now they don't want that discussion
and I'm not sure how you get you should
be able to get fair-minded people on
both sides to discuss it but that's the
problem are you going to find
fair-minded people on both sides and I
don't know how to convince them I would
say that you know there's a big brouhaha
over the company that owns my show full
measure called Sinclair if you saw the
little squares of the anchors reading
the same thing over and over all that
was was a promo distributed to all the
stations that Sinclair owns this is a
not an uncommon practice at national
local news I've worked for local news
stations CNN PBS CBS we do joint promos
with the locals sometimes at the local
we're told what kind of promos to do or
Dan Rather is sent to us
you know when I was in local news I had
to interview dan Rather on my noon show
when he came to do a promotional
appearance you know this stuff is common
and you can argue whether it should be
or not but it wasn't strange that
Sinclair was issuing this promotion and
sort of a mission statement really to
its affiliates and do you know what it
said and this is I'll give you some
verbatim little bits of quotes it simply
said that in this era of fake news there
been a lot of mistakes and inaccuracies
reported that we they're saying in our
local stations are gonna check our facts
and try to be as accurate and fair as
possible and that news we see is neither
left nor right it should just be factual
that was the that's became became an
international controversy last week
because people didn't read the promo
that's what the promo said so then I had
journalism friends of mine argue they
were just out of their minds about this
and I said read the promo is there
anything in there you don't agree with
because if there is something you
disagree with you shouldn't be in this
business because it's all just basic you
know news should be neither left nor
right should be fair it should be
accurate and even said at the end
we're not perfect we'll probably make
mistakes and we want to hear from you
and it gave you know a website to go to
or an email address I don't see how you
argue with any of that but one of my
friends said well you know it uses the
charged Trump terms the charge Trump and
I'm like fair and accurate neither left
nor right and I know they met you know
that there's too much fake news which I
had to break the news to him that Trump
didn't think up for the phrase just like
I told you guys so I don't know there's
just this weird I feel the same way you
do you should be able to have rational
discussions with people that they won't
touch they're just kind of entrenched
and few points about all this we have
time for one more question yeah I was
just wondering YouTube promotes certain
news outlets and does not do the same
with others so it sort of puts other
ones down like Tucker Carlson you won't
see on the front page of YouTube first
of all do you think this is at the
at all considering that their their own
corporation and second law do you think
they have a that this will have an
effect at all well it's back to the
Trump effect I mean the Clinton people
dump clearly dominated social media and
pretty much everywhere you looked online
and yet Trump still wants so it doesn't
have an impact probably some but there
are enough people I think who do look
past that should they be doing it well I
don't like that they do it but I'm kind
of mixed on that because for whatever
reason these companies are highly
successful their businesses they don't
owe you no they don't owe me or you
anything in particular they don't know
Tucker Carlson anything they kind of can
operate you know I'm not a person that
pontificates are analyzed as a sort of
thing but from my view they have a right
as a business to do pretty much what
they want with this whole Facebook
controversy I don't like the data
breaches but you know I checked off all
the boxes and never read any of it to
and I knew my date it was going places
and I know when I see these ads pop up
on my Facebook page that have to do with
something I just emailed somebody about
that they're looking at my stuff so I
don't like it but some of this is also
free enterprise I'm not sure how far
their responsibility goes just because
they became a big successful company I
think the other side needs to you know
hopefully get in there with their own
their own ways their own companies well
thank you all very much was a pleasure
being here I appreciate you have
okay Thank You sharyl Attkisson
I should mention before we get to our
next speaker that among the many items
on the literature table littered
literature tables outside is a flyer for
the 2019 Hillsdale College cruise which
will sail around the British Isles that
trip is going to take place in June of
2019 we'll be sailing round-trip from
Southampton aboard the Regent Seven Seas
Explorer the cruise among other things
is going to be celebrating the
completion of the Winston Churchill
biography all 31 volumes of it we're
also planning a post cruise program with
the Churchill theme in and around London
and that will include a visit to
Chartwell Churchill's country home so if
you're interested I encourage you to
pick up a flyer I also note that we're
going to be packing up the literature
after lunch